so i i have a um
i have i want to run for an office okay
and this is this is what i would
advocate for
i'm so scared
let's return our rights
hear me out okay you know yeah yeah i
don't like to drive
i'm not even a good driver
[Music]
i don't like to cook in saudi arabia
these girls they're like oh they can't
drive i'm like we didn't have to then on
top of that voting right
right voting okay
why pay attention to politics and we
could just let the men do it for us okay
then i don't have to do that okay hear
me out everyone wanted to work who who
are these women that wanted to work i
could be chilling at home on youtube
please get married at 18.
marriage
return it return it i am ready to be a
housewife i i'm not against i'm not
against that okay so so so this is what
and like nowadays this is where we
fumbled the bag in the back in the old
days they would have to like do the
laundry manually all this stuff right
nowadays it's automated if we just
waited
like another couple decades
it would be an easy housewife roll
roomba
automated laundry you don't have to hang
it outside like i would be like
and we gotta cook when there's there's
uber eats now and you there's like all
these cooking services like i think i
would i would be lying if i like i know
there are some women who maybe feel like
they've got a lot to prove if you told
me i could live life on easy mode i'd
live life on easy mode i think women
live life and easily
i would live life we do we do live life
on easy mode i think you know how many
advantages you get just from being a
young attractive girl that men don't get
i think that a lot i'm gonna be and this
is this is very anti-feminist to me but
i think a lot of women
don't live life on easy mode because
they feel like they have something to
prove and i'm like i'm not gonna lie i'm
100 if in if a rich old man that i found
physically attractive and therefore
would happily have sex with if they were
like amy i'm going to financially take
care of you you can not work you can do
her dms are open
100 please 100
if if a rich you don't need to be rich
you need to just be if a man and this is
anti-feminist but if a man said to me
amy i will take care of you you don't
have to work you just have to and
genuinely yeah if a man wins what do you
get what do you get what do you get
sexual favors on command
not on command what do you mean he's
he's taking care of all your bills yeah
but sometimes the coochie is tight
sometimes
i'm tired like
everybody's taking care 100 of the bills
i'll make it work
would you let him sleep with other women
um
that would depend on if i was like
emotionally attached to him if like oh
that would like
he's only going to take care of you
and fund your entire lifestyle that you
want
if you accept him he's going to sleep
with other women yeah but then i'd sleep
with other men no no no no you can't see
what i mean because you're not paying
for his life
but to be fair i have a vibrator so i'd
be like you know what if i've got a
comfortable life and it's just sex like
if i really cared about him then that's
like different but if i was only with
him for the money and the comfort yeah
you care you can't you care about him
you care about him you like who he is he
says i'm gonna take care of you you live
the lifestyle you want but you have to
accept that he's going to sleep with
other people
i wouldn't like it but knowing me i've
stayed with cheetahs i've stayed with
cheetahs so i'd just be like cheating
because he's not lying
do you know what i think that would be
more on me that'd be more on me if he
cheated and my self-esteem or my worth
or xyz if i went amy do you want
commitment stability uh exclusivity or
do you want discomfort in this lifestyle
and if i went
i prioritize this confidence lifestyle
then i would have to be like i'm asking
you right now would you prioritize that
or would you prioritize exclusivity
i don't know i don't i don't know i
didn't
would you choose
i already know
you're taking that lifestyle baby oh no
i'm kidding i wouldn't do cheating
actually you wouldn't you if you could
if you could give you the lifestyle that
you wanted you wouldn't take it i'll go
to my dad what do i need him for her
no no i mean i can't but like like they
always say like women's have mating
strategies yeah and there's five mating
strategies have i talked to you about
these no for women
yeah and i always forget the fifth so if
anyone in the chat knows the fifth i
forget these but it's like so when we
see a guy there's like five guys
basically that represent so one is the
guy at the foam cannon party well i
don't know what that is what's just they
call they call a guy that's a man of
spirit term the guys they got the chat
gets it
that's the guy that's like really hot
like really just like physically
attractive like he has the jeans we want
right so that's like the girls that have
like a one-night stand with the guy
that's that's why they call me they met
him at the foam cannon party
and just i don't know i don't know what
came over yeah that's that's guy number
one okay strategy jeans right yeah next
mating strategy parental investment yeah
so we want to know this is a guy we meet
and we think he would stick around if i
we got if i got pregnant like i think he
would like provide time yeah second
thing is money so i think he could be he
has the resources kind of like the alpha
beta thing yeah but like he has the
resources to like take care of the guy
fourth is legacy now legacy is like not
embarrassing the family and like having
like character be like work ethic like
that sort of thing but yeah and that's
like when i was talking to my friend
torsha who taught me this the other day
um would you go subscribe to her channel
um she she said that's what when i talk
about like what i look for like that's
what i look for is legacy yeah because
like the the
money isn't as big like i'd rather have
legacy yeah yeah so like i don't want a
guy that's like embarrassing because
even if like you don't get caught
you know what's even worse i think
they're getting worse than getting
cheated on is like everybody knew you
got cheated on yeah i'm telling you yeah
that is the worst that is the worst
feeling
embarrassing so and i don't know what
the fifth one was if anyone knows in the
chat because i forget well do you know
the uh different mating strategies for
men
um i would guess so so low body count
because they want to make sure the kid
is theirs yep so and then i would guess
um
like like someone that would be a good
mother of the kid so like femininity
maybe like being like kind that sort of
thing um
in shape because like the the hips right
they like wide hips that's what i got
you guys like ass because it's like the
birthing hips or something there's like
a bilateral thing
um and like men haven't men when i say
men in the west men haven't always liked
but in the black culture always has been
but i think the only reason that arse is
a thing now is because hip-hop is
mainstream well i think it's like like i
don't even think it's ass in itself but
like like the hit the hits child-bearing
hits
yeah yeah and then like the boobs is
like i don't know the kids suck i don't
know
there's something with that too
um
yeah i think that's all the ones i could
think of off the top of my head
i would agree i would agree
i think um
i think the promiscuous is honestly how
quickly she sleeps with him
promiscuous as in like if she sleeps in
quickly he's going to see her as more
promiscuous than if she doesn't do do
you think that
if she has a kid that changes
whether he sees it 100 yeah because you
can't you can't yeah i'll be honest
would you would you tell your female
clients if they have a kid to like kind
of throw that strategy out the door like
he he ain't going to see you is probably
not i would i would say that having a
child to a man is compromising
for him yeah and i would explain that it
is natural in male because as the male
it is we are expected to sacrifice for
the woman and for the child
and there is nothing biologically and
naturally worse than a man sacrificing
himself for offspring that isn't his
that's why in the lion kingdom the first
thing that male does is he kills the
cubs boy if a new male takes over the
pride he kills those cubs because he's
like if i'm putting my life on the line
for this pride best believe i'm doing it
for my genes not anyone else's
so
um
i'll be honest i know a few of my
friends would be like honestly they'd
have sex with someone who had a kid but
they they probably wouldn't marry them
if they have other options they probably
wouldn't
but do you think like girls should still
hold out if they have a kid hold out
like on sex
because how is he going to view you as
not promiscuous if you have a child i
would say
i would say yes because
here's the thing when a woman
when i say hold out not like hold out
for three months when a woman doesn't
engage in sex with a guy quickly that's
part of the vetting process for saying
which is he the kind of guy who's gonna
stick around for you
is he the kind of guy and if he's not
that kind of guy
then he's not gonna
he's not gonna stick around if you don't
do what i mean but if he is the kind of
guy who could stick around
then it's in your interest to not be
sexually quick with him because
that's the best way as opposed to being
sexually quickly because then he'd be
like okay well probably not do you know
what i mean do you so it's interesting
cause i always hear from like in the red
pill they tell guys if she doesn't sleep
with you within three dates to like move
on because she's not genuinely attracted
to you
i don't i don't i don't i don't agree
with that i think it's i have a rule i
tell guys who are coach if she doesn't
kiss you within the first three dates
for sure move on
um
but i would say the biggest thing is
having sexual progression
so if let's say she doesn't kiss you on
the first date but then actually kisses
you in the second date but let's say
it's not a full-out kiss it's like a
peck on her lips or whatever fine let's
say the third date she kisses you with
some tongues there's a better hands
going somewhere there's sexual
progression that's good
and in fact if i was being honest if i
was dating a girl i'm going to take that
girl more seriously than the girl who
has sex with me on the first date
whereas if it's a girl if you don't get
anything for the three dates facts move
on she's not into you she doesn't have
general desire if she doesn't sleep with
you no maybe she's just a woman who's
worthy of being a wife when do you okay
when would you tell a guy
to like like to move on if she
like how long would you say look it she
hasn't slept with you within that long
you gotta go boy
i had this situation recently um
if she hasn't slept yeah yeah
have they done anything or no
have they done have they done nothing
nothing past making out
nothing past making out yeah
they say okay let's say you're going on
an average one day a week
right after five weeks you haven't you
haven't gone past kissing after five
weeks nah bounce bro
[Music]
i'm out because it's interesting because
i'll hear men like i kind of understand
both sides a little bit yeah yeah yeah
what would you say would you tell me
like men
yeah oh gosh it's hard because
god it depends on the girl you're like
if it was me i didn't kiss it till the
sixth month oh god six no i would tell
them to move on six months
no it's just more like like okay i know
girls that'll make guys hold out because
they don't view them in that way
i think guys don't view them or she
doesn't like like she'll sleep with one
guy right away but she'll make another
guy wait because she doesn't view the
one guy in that way
like she's more in that way she's more
attracted to the guy that she slept with
straight away yeah
i think she's more physically attracted
yeah but i don't think that's the one
who she values more
because women who i think women who
you tell me what you think i think women
if they're
if a guy
doesn't have a lot of
qualities that's good for long term so
let's say
stable whatever but he's
really attractive she'll sleep with him
because she's like oh well whatever
but if he does have a lot of great
qualities long term and she's attracted
to him
if she's clever she won't sleep with him
straight away
because she knows that probably is gonna
eliminate her as long term in his eyes
i i would say sometimes sometimes but it
kind of it kind of goes bad i hate these
terms i hate to do it
but i think a lot of times the girls
like views the one guy is more beta
i think i think i think there's like
there's like um a level of attraction
where a girl will have and i just think
like
i don't that's the problem is it's
really hard to distinguish and it really
depends on the girl
yeah you don't you know what i'm saying
yeah because i think i've had it like i
i've had it where
sounds so bad i don't know
i'll just be honest i've had it where
like really attractive girls
have been like
some have like just slept with these
straight away
and then they've been girls who
arguably a lot of guys she's attractive
not as attractive but because she really
didn't want to [ __ ] her up she
she didn't sleep with me straight away
because she was like i don't want to
lose the chance of having this guy
as a serious term i don't that might be
what she told you maybe what i mean
i'll be honest man it happens
well she definitely asked me to be her
boyfriend or whatever yeah oh my god
how'd that go for her
uh one of two of them i said no one of
them
we were together for two oh yeah yeah
okay